es gibt schlachten die in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen weil sie eben
entscheidende wendepunkte eines ganzen
krieges sind sozusagen militärische
superlative wie stalingrad die schlacht
von el alamein oder die wichtige landung
der alliierten in der normandie auch in
putins krieg gegen die ukraine da gibt
es so eine schlacht nämlich die schlacht
von host hommel der russische präsident
und seine militär ist die hatten
durchaus ein meister plan wie sie die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew direkt in
den ersten stunden dieses krieges zum
fall bringen würden und er hatte im
grunde genommen einen angriff vor putin
der so überwältigend und so erdrückend
war wie wir ihn in europa in den
vergangenen 70 80 jahren gott sei dank
muss man sagen nicht mehr gesehen hatten
doch dann gab es eben eine gruppe
unfassbar mutiger ukrainischer soldaten
die sich diesen russischen angreifern
heldenhaft in den weg gestellt haben und
diese entscheidende schlacht von horst
engel die möchte ich ihnen heute genau
erklären weil ich sie eben für so
außergewöhnlich und für so wichtig halte
es ist also der 24 februar etwa 8 uhr
morgens als eine formation von 34
russischen hubschraubern aus belarus in
die ukraine eindringt ihr ziel ein
sogenannter luft sturmangriff auf das
flugfeld von rostock im norden von kiew
etwa 20 kilometer von kiew entfernt an
der spitze tödliche k 52 alligator
kampfhubschrauber
bewaffnet mit einer 30 mm maschine kann
ohne lenkflugkörpern und raketen
dahinter sehen wir dann die acht
transporthubschrauber die die
eigentliche kampftruppe an diesem morgen
transportieren nämlich 300 russische
fallschirmjäger diese deshalb niki
gelten als absolute elite der russischen
armee handyaufnahmen die halten diesen
sturmangriff fest der mann muss das fast
so zynisch sagen aussieht wie aus einem
hollywood blockbuster irgendwie
unwirklich aussieht was da am himmel bei
kiew passiert die ukraine die versuchen
noch die russen mit flugabwehr raketen
abzuschießen putins schrauber die von
toys körper maschinengewehr salven und
selbst eben auch raketen was diese
schlacht auch so ungewöhnlich und so
unglaublich macht sie wurde eben
wirklich von beiden seiten dokumentiert
wir haben einmal die handy aufnahmen
gesehen dass hier das sind jetzt
aufnahmen von helmkameras der russischen
piloten und soldaten wir sehen wie die
hubschrauber im tiefflug über das
flughafengelände rauschen und immer
wieder schießen und immer wieder töten
und dann schlagen die fallschirmjäger zu
diese sogenannten kräfte der ersten
stunde die haben damals vor allem ein
ziel sie sollen das flughafengelände
stürmen und die riesige landebahn von
horst engel sicher denn wladimir putin
der will einen man kann das so sagen
blitzkrieg sieg gegen die ukraine denn
in russland da staaten genau zu diesem
zeitpunkt bereits 18 vollgepackte die
luccin transportflugzeuge die wiederum
sollen dann auf dem gerade eroberten
flughafenausbau landen und so
tausende weitere russische falsche mega
ins ziel bringt wenige stunden nach
kriegsbeginn dann stünden eben eine
russische übermacht direkt an den toren
kiels und dass ich alles gesagt wirklich
wenige stunden nach kriegsbeginn direkt
vor der ukrainischen hauptstadt diese
schocken ort taktik zu deutsch schrecken
und furcht die hat ein ziel die ukraine
so schockierend so verunsichern dass sie
dann kampflos die waffen niederlegen und
in den ersten stunden der schlacht von
horst rommel da sieht es auch aus als
würde putins plan eben voll aufgeben
doch wladimir putin und seine militärs
die haben an diesem morgen und in all
ihren planungen den kampfeswillen den
mut und die entschlossenheit der ukraine
vollkommen unterschätzt denn diese
ukraine diese ukrainischen soldaten die
leben nicht ihre waffen nieder sie
greifen zu diesen waffen und werfen sich
selbst in unterzahl dem russischen
blitzangriff entgegen denn klar die
ukraine die wissen sie kämpfen hier um
ihre hauptstadt um irland und eben um
ihre heimat ein video das zeigt wie aus
dem westen kias ukrainische mi 8
transporthubschrauber in richtung horst
engel fliegen sozusagen der gegenangriff
der ukraine 50 ukrainische falsche mega
die landen dann pirschen sich über ein
weltweit weg vor und die wissen in dem
moment sie müssen ist irgendwie auf das
flughafengelände schaffen irgendwie die
russischen transportmaschinen und die
verstärkungen die da auf dem weg nach
ihr ist noch irgendwie stoppen unser
grafiker die haben dann speziell für sie
aufbereitet was in den minuten danach
passiert auf diesem flughafen gelände
denn als die ersten soldaten über die
mit stacheldraht gesicherte flughafen
mauer tätern werden sie von den
russischen angreifern eigentlich sofort
entdeckt und sofort geraten die ukraine
unter mg feuer zu keiner werden
getroffen und eben auch direkt getötet
in ihrer verzweiflung der graben die
soldaten kunde versuchen ihre verletzten
kameraden irgendwie von diesem
flughafengelände zu retten aber
dann eben passiert das eigentlich
unglaublich denn die ukraine die halten
stand es gelingt ihnen
artillerieunterstützung zurufen
verstärkung zu rufen und dann wendet
sich tatsächlich das blatt es gelingt
den ukrainern die russen die eigentliche
überzahl sind zurückzudrängen und selbst
flugabwehrstellungen zu errichten und
dann hören sie die entscheidende
nachricht die russischen angreifer die
haben tatsächlich ihren plan aufgegeben
und in diesem moment der drehen ihre
transportmaschinen in der luft um eine
gruppe mutiger ukrainischer soldaten ist
es also gelungen genau in diesem moment
leider mir putins vielleicht wichtigsten
kriegs plan zu durchkreuzen und zu
stoppen kurz danach veröffentlichen dann
die ukraine ein foto auf facebook
erschöpfte erleichterte soldaten die
stolz in ihrer hand die von kugeln
durchlöchert
ukrainische flagge wäre das flugfeld von
horst engel damals gefallen vermutlich
wäre dann auch die ukrainische
hauptstadt kiew kurz danach gefallen der
ganze krieg wahrscheinlich in wenigen
stunden entschieden für wladimir putin
und seine russischen soldaten so aber
wird der vormarsch der russen gestoppt
dann noch tagelang um dieses flugfeld
gekämpft bis die region schließlich ende
märz nahezu vollständig von den
ukrainern befreit werden kann eben ein
entscheidender wendepunkt im verlauf
dieses krieges ich glaube die schlacht
von horst engel die wird in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen sowie der
unendliche wut und diese unglaubliche
entschlossenheit der ukrainischen
soldaten